Ná thúc tần chú môn chêu tiền gà xin ở á rận lời nhá lệnh đạo nước này, ông Kim trận ơn,
bưa ra ngại hai mức hả chiến tại của họ, hồn gị nhân dân tối cao chú tiền khá nịch.
Chêu tiền sẽ không bao giờ từ bỏ chú chính hạnh nhân,
sống sẵn đủ thoại về Mỹ,
nếu Washington từ bỏ yêu cầu phi hạnh nhân quá,
nhiều một điều kiện đàn phán.
Theo Kim, nếu Mỹ mong muốn theo đổi việc tổn tại họ bình với chêu tiền,
dựa trên sự công nhận thực tế, không có lý rau gì,
mình nếu lại từ chối đàn phán đủ Washington,
dù đến ngọt khả năng đạo phán đủ Mỹ,
sống nhờ đến đạo chú tiền lại bác khả năng đủy thoại về hành Quốc.
Ông cụ bác bỏ kế hoại phi hạnh nhân,
bà dài đoạn mà hành Quốc lệ xuất,
đúng thời châu dòng việc thống nhất bản đạo chú tiền,
là điều không cần thiết.